[Music]
you're taking me somewhere to kill me
no i'm taking you someplace to talk well
i don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did
because we both know you love to talk
wow well loki
uh it's been a long journey um
it's been uh i mean technically
i think for audiences it's been 10 years
but for me it's been about 12 years
since i first auditioned i first
auditioned um in 2009
uh and in the spring and i think many
people are aware i auditioned for the
role of thor
initially casting director randy hiller
and um sarah finn seemed to think that
you know
i was tall and blonde and so i could
try have a go um but um as everybody
knows
uh i came out of that process as loki
and it was really interesting because
i think even in the minds of of
everybody at marvel studios
both roles were still malleable
obviously everyone knew who thor and
loki were from
the comics and from norse mythology but
they wanted to
find two actors who could play brothers
and who were both
a kind of a foil for each other and a
match for each other
and they found the great chris hemsworth
the mighty thor himself
and uh and me and um
it was an amazing time you know we were
i think
kevin feige and kenneth branagh called
chris five minutes before they called me
and then
got us together very quickly and and um
we met in the uk about a week after that
two weeks after that
um and we all hang out together and and
um
and it was the beginning of this
extraordinary journey which has changed
both of our lives and i remember that
very very well
because it had been quite a long um
process in the auditions and for both of
us and
and um we kind of at that point didn't
expect
to get to get to where we we eventually
got to
and um they had announced i think that
anthony hopkins would be playing
odin our father and that kind of was
was something to get used to um and rene
rousseau playing uh friega
and natalie portman playing jane foster
and we just just felt like the two
luckiest guys in the world and
at the beginning of a really long and
unknown journey which is really exciting
and it's always been nice to have him
kind of alongside sort of you know we
both can't quite believe
where we are you know it's been a it's
been a life-changing thing for sure
and what is this new found love for the
frost giants
you could have killed them all with your
bare hands
and changed so have i
now fight me
you know that first film um remains
incredibly special in my memory it was a
really
this extraordinary group of people
actually um
and and perhaps it's
maybe it's my memory kind of filtering
it with a kind of golden
halo but but i really remember it as a
as a very
um we were all very aware of it was a
good script and they were
and everybody involved was extremely
talented and working
kind of above and beyond their
capacities to make this the best it
could be
and that was across the board across the
cast certainly
um that kenneth branagh had this
extraordinary vision
of asgard and the royal family at the
center of it and these
dynamics within quite a complex family
that were very felt very real but also
very
um appropriately heightened for this is
the royal family and they govern the
order of the universe and so if things
go wrong between
fathers and sons or two brothers the
stakes are high
because the uh because it matters
um and both chris and i have talked
about we owe so much to ken brunner
because he was such a kind
and inspiring director for us as young
actors a brilliant actress director
but also it was really his vision of
asgard he built
this world that we've played in for ten
years and and set up the rules of it and
the palace and the costumes and
um his long-time collaborator alex byrne
who
alexandra byrne who made the costumes um
working with concept artists who'd been
at marvel studios
uh charlie wen and ryan meinerding
who i remember walking into alex's
fitting room for the first time and she
had these images which have been drawn
by uh ryan or charlie uh charlie wen or
ryan minerving
and they were images of thor and loki
but with
our faces on and so it was kind of
taking inspiration from different comic
books and different runs of the comics
from the 60s 70s 80s 90s
they'd put their own spin on it and alex
was saying right we have to bring that
two-dimensional picture into a 3d
movie and see if we can make it work
capes helmets breastplates
you know the hammer the staff um
all these kind of i mean knew he had to
be able to fight in it and
emote in it and act in it and and so
it was an extraordinary journey towards
that first moment of stepping into the
costume
and a production designer called beau
welch who built
asgard who built the royal palace and um
our director of photography harris
zamboa lucas who's worked a lot with
kenneth branagh
and so many of the choices we made in
that first film
have they've had a long they've cast a
long shadow across all the films
about um specifically about
that central triangle about odin thor
and loki and the dynamic
between them really a very kind of
relatable
story about fathers and sons and
brothers and loki obviously feeling
instinctively isolated and not
understanding why
and then finding out in fact that he was
adopted
and that suddenly all sorts of things
making sense to him about his childhood
and him feeling very
betrayed and angry and and and um
upset and and sad and lonely and then
that
all that sort of fragmenting the
relationship with thor
and then they kind of go off in
different directions and
and that's a big moment for both of them
all of you beneath me i am a god you
dull creature and i will not be bullied
by that
yeah it was so fun i mean loki is a
character who's been around
for thousands of years and he was in the
you know ancient norse myths and he's
been in
um various you know in he
turns up in opera and in theater and in
literature
and and then he turns up in the marvel
comics in the 60s
and stan lee makes him the antagonist in
the thor
in the thor run and he has such
amazing rage because he is
mystifies and playful and witty and
charismatic and charming
and fun but he's also broken
and damaged and vulnerable and jealous
and he's full of grievance and a kind of
unprocessed pain and anger
and the cocktail of those things the wit
and the charm and the vulnerability and
the
um and the grievance and you just shake
it up and you have this really
this character who can change shape and
he's the shape-shifter the trickster
somebody who's transgressive and
disruptive
who exists on this line between good and
bad
and that's was my entry point for
avengers was i knew that
i felt very lucky that in the way loki
had been written in thor
by uh don payne
who's sadly no longer with us had so
much pathos
that i thought if i can put a shell
around the pathos
and um and put a bit of uh
put some stakes in it you know he's
someone who now understands who he is
and i knew the structure of the film
was such that the movie's called
avengers
and the avengers are the good guys
and if the film's gonna work they need a
bad guy and that was gonna be me
and and so to really lean into the the
my position as the antagonist but still
so he was you know he's playing this
game of chess he's trying to
um kind of outwit and outsmart
every avenger he gets a one he gets a
kind of one-on-one with everybody
um and because he's so clever
and so um manipulative he kind of turns
them against each other which is why
they're
then they're kind of disparate in the
first and second act of that film
but then they unite to stop him and i
realized there had to be something quite
kind of
purely villainous about loki in that
film um
because for the film to work you know
you wanna you hopefully cheer when
he loses and he does
he gets his i think it's his right foot
gets grabbed by the hulk and he gets
smashed around
like a rag doll and and and that's the
end of loki really there's no
no coming back after that
you must be truly desperate to come to
me for help
what makes you think you can trust me i
don't
mother did
so yeah for the dark world
um we we made that quite shortly after
avengers was released and so we chris
and i came into that
experience kind of very fresh off the
back of the avengers
and um i knew that loki was going to be
this very different he wasn't going to
be the main villain
that was going to be malikith played by
christopher eccleston
and loki's function in the story was was
as a kind of
wingman in a way to thor that they form
based around the grief
that they feel uh because of the death
of their mother
they have to form a very
a spontaneous and unstable alliance
and they're united by their shared grief
and they want to
to stop the dark elves from um
accomplishing their mission
to return the universe to darkness um
and there was such a fun
quality to the dynamic between thor and
loki because all of that
their sort of um pre-history as brothers
and they have a kind of playful
fractious teasing relationship
comes out in that film and
i knew in the script there was a moment
where
thor and loki are stranded
on the dark world quite literally the
home of the dark elves
svar telefine uh and
with jane foster played by natalie
portman um
and they in in a battle with the dark
elves
um it becomes very dangerous for both of
them
and um they
are they lose they are losing in a
one-on-one
skirmish and they're surrounded and
thor is taking um a
very substantial and very painful
beating from
algorithm or curse and that loki
somehow
in some change of heart or
extraordinary act of courage decides to
help his brother
uh and and distract
um algorithm or curse so that for a
moment
thor can get back on his feet
and in so doing actually is mortally
wounded
and sacrifices himself
it was written as a very poignant moment
because
loki is untrustworthy and
mercurial and you're never quite sure
what his motivations are
and thor is constantly questioning
whether he can trust his brother
and he probably can't but in this one
moment loki seems to have made an
unselfish
altruistic generous act but it's cost
him his life
and i remember thinking this is a big
moment this is going to be this is the
end of loki
finally you realize he does love his
brother
and he certainly loves his mother and he
maybe even loves his father
um but they never got to bury the
hatchet
um and
make peace and we played the death scene
as completely sincere it was goodbye
it was goodbye to loki it was goodbye
for me
um i remember it was a big day on set
and
um people were really really generous
and sensitive about it and
we played it you know for real and um
chris i remember gave a very like moving
performance as well and
and um i thought okay that's it that's
the end of that's the end of loki and
then
uh we were wrapped on principal
photography and
months went by and i think a good six
months actually and then i
got a call from kevin feige saying you
know
loki was you know supposed to die
well we have tested the film and
um in test screenings
people the first thing people said was
well where's loki
and um and they said and we said well
you know you saw what happened he uh
he makes the sacrifice play and and
that's it
and they went well obviously he just
he's not really dead
and they went uh you know maybe maybe
maybe
i think he i think he maybe is um i mean
i think
uh and and the audience says well
obviously we don't believe that
they just didn't accept that loki was
really dead they thought he would
somehow find
some spontaneous trick or or
or or way of getting out of it and it
was a kind
it was made them all scratch their heads
at marvel studios and think
um right okay we better rethink this and
then that's how they came up with the
the new ending which is that um loki had
faked his own death
and was now and had shape-shifted into
an asgardian guard and was now
impersonating
odin sitting on the throne which then
led us into
the beginning of ragnarok where it's
loki pretending to be odin
and he's pretended to be odin for quite
a long time
um which is quite the spell to keep up
um quite the trick for the trickster
and it became a really fun new way to
end the film and begin the next one so
yeah it was bizarre and so we and and um
you know an ending is just a new
beginning
hey let's do get help what get help
no come on you love it i hate it it's
great it works every time it's
humiliating do you have a better plan no
we're doing it we are not doing get help
well what i've really enjoyed most of
all is is that complexity
is is his place in
his place at the table of the gods has
always
been occupying a position of
unpredictability and chaos
and spontaneity and across the stories
of loki from thousands of years ago
the most interesting aspect for me is
that he was someone the gods
the other gods ode and thor friga they
had to sort of put up with and endure
because he was unstable
and treacherous and you couldn't quite
trust him and
he was sometimes chaotic in an unhelpful
way
and then occasionally necessary
and when everybody else had run out of
ideas it was loki's idea
that was a bit out of left field
unconventional
but might be the thing that we need and
might be the thing that saves us in the
end
and i've always been drawn to this idea
that loki's chaos
is occasionally something we need that
not everything can be ordered and
sometimes and everything can be planned
and prepared and
been done by the book but loki somehow
as this
unpredictable spirit there's somebody
who crosses boundaries and
questions everything and changes shape
and has a kind of a wit and an
intelligence
and lots of different cards to play is
something that is
once you know once in a blue moon
useful that's what i've loved about loki
is that you're never quite sure
what his motivations are you're never
quite sure
if his if he's being sincere and you
don't know if you can trust him or not
and that i think i hope audiences can
see
that there is good in him
there always was and there are also
these other
instincts that are drawn towards um
something less virtuous but there he he
he himself is
is a cocktail of all these ingredients
perhaps
he's not truly good and he's not truly
bad he's somewhere in the middle
and um i think i find that just a very
complex
interesting part to play um
because let's not forget he's also the
god of mischief
and mischief in itself is i once looked
it up in the dictionary because i was
really curious and it's
like an inclination to playfulness
and i thought what a wonderful thing to
inhabit a character whose incarnation is
playful
and sometimes playfulness is about you
know stepping outside the box i guess
what i love about loki in this show
is it's the loki you know in a world you
don't know
and loki's someone who's always been
very controlled always been someone
who's
quite confident in the cards he's got in
his hand and which cards he's going to
play
and and the series loki
puts loki in a position where he is out
of control
out of his comfort zone um and
a fish out of water and that's very
confronting for him
you you take away his status you take
away his
magic you take away his power his
costume
the context that he's familiar with his
brother asgard his father
all the things he's used to and he put
him in
this new context of the tva the time
variance
authority who are a bureaucratic
organization
tasked with ordering time making sure
that reality
unfolds according to predetermined
decisions
so you have this massive
institution that represents order and
you have this mercurial spirit it
represents chaos
and that's where our show starts
you